so i think we were supposed to have put
your records on play there it is you
know that song by grammy award-winning
artist corinne bailey ray just one of
her infectious feel-good hits and just
like a star you can catch her live at
encore theater i'd win this friday let's
welcome her to las vegas now
hey karoon
hey how you doing i'm good how are you
look at those glasses
oh thank you i just got them yesterday
oh they are yesterday we played in l.a
and today we're heading to santa barbara
i'm on my tours right now but you can
see the world whizzing by
it's an extremely bumpy ride but i'm in
here with you and i'm looking forward to
coming over to vegas oh my have you you
have you ever been to vegas i'm assuming
you have yes yes i've been a few times
the first time i ever came was with
norah jones we did a big show
laura and i and then i came over and
played my own show and i saw the love
and the beatles love cirque du soleil
yeah yeah sandwich was just incredible i
don't know if it's still on now but that
was one of the most basic visual things
i've ever seen so
um yeah that will stick in my mind
for a big vegas experience yes and now
we have so many news shows happening so
you have to try and catch one on your
one one night only performance here at
the win on friday but i have to ask you
first and foremost you know what records
have you been putting on lately what's
what are you listening to letting your
hair down too
what do i listen to like my head optic i
mean i listen to those weird music like
i like to sing to classical music i like
just a kovich when we're on oh i try not
to listen to any music but i like to
hear the sounds around me so i like to
hear the birds singing now she's on the
patio in
los angeles and i had the amazing
hummingbirds and the weird sound that
they make you know we don't have them in
england so tuning into different bird
song and different environmental sounds
for me it's really inspiring it helps me
it helps me think of new songs and new
ideas that's beautiful well speaking of
new songs and new ideas your show is on
friday at the encore theater you know
you've been this is your first solo tour
in five years or so so do we have any
new music coming out that you'll be
performing on stage throughout the tour
we've got new music and we play our new
music and the sound checks but this tour
is really a kind of combination of uh
some of my favorite songs so far so it's
everything from my last three records
and ep
and i think we've just been away so long
it's really nice to
reacquaint people you know i want people
to hear the songs that they grew up with
the songs that their parents used to
play them driving in the car the songs
that they maybe went to college with or
people tell me i had a baby to this song
they made a baby
so yeah it's kind of that sort of it's a
feel good the tour's called sunlight
sunlight and it's just a joyous
celebration of the music i've made so
far and kind of reconnecting with the
audience so yeah that's what it is
there's no um
there's no sitting there trying out the
new song it's all about singing along to
the ones that you know really well i
love that and you've always made such
feel-good music i know everyone that
will be at your show on friday will
leave in a better mood right
thank you i always say when i finish my
show my sheets hurt smiling
so i'm just sort of smiling i'm smiling
at the audience and smiling at the thing
and there's money back and it's like
it's kind of two hours of like face gym
or something but yeah we always have a
really nice time together oh my gosh
well you can get tickets to your show on
friday at win las vegas dot com and just
one more time you know just tell us what
you love about vegas and why you're
excited to come here
i love the energy i love the fact that
people are passing through they're on a
holiday they're on a break on the trip
they're with the girlfriends or the
partners and and then i just think you
can be spontaneous you know there's so
many great music acts there you don't
have to decide until the last minute
like let's go but let's try this out
let's see the show let's do something we
wouldn't normally do when we're at home
you take a big gang or go on your own or
come for the second half or however you
want to do it you know i really like the
spontaneity of that place
that is perfect so friday let's just go
karim bailey ray at the win on court
theater thank you so much for